[Music]
dozens of marines and sailors will storm
the Southern California beaches today in
a test that could shape the next
generation of warfare the troops are
taking part in an advanced technology
exercise the devices they're using could
be used in future assaults on enemy
coastlines first on CBS this morning
Carter Evans shows us the high-tech
tools meant to give American troops the
upper hand he's on the beach at Camp
Pendleton north of San Diego Carter good
morning good morning this is just some
of the new hardware the Marines are
testing out here these are autonomous
vehicles one for land one for sea you
can see they both got machine guns
mounted to them this is a drone with a
very high-tech camera well what's so
special about that it can actually see
in the dark it's an infrared camera
it reads heat signatures that gives
commanders the ability to make smart
decisions before they put Marines on the
beach
on the sand in the air and in the water
the Marines here at Camp Pendleton are
training for the next generation of
warfare
let's go Mike Sarah five six five
braving throughout my entire career
maritime supremacy was guaranteed air
supremacy was guaranteed now even a
primitive adversary like Isis is flying
UAVs with explosive charges on them so
the pressure is on it pressures on
Colonel Dan Sullivan is trying to
relieve that pressure by putting new
high-tech tools in the hands of his
Marines from mobile 3d printers that can
create spare parts in the field two
unmanned robots mounted with machine
guns
the unique thing here is having the
actual scientists and engineers in the
field for two weeks testing and
evaluating a host of technologies this
week's exercise brings together more
than 100 pieces of advanced technology
and lets Marines work with them in
simulated amphibious assault scenarios
but putting so much faith in autonomous
devices raises concerns over hacking
this is being designed with the cyber
threat in mind if there's no cyber
security it's no good I think that's
quickly becoming our center of gravity
he's defending our network can hold how
many rounds probably 200 the technology
was designed by both military and
civilian innovators but not all of it
was originally intended for the
battlefield such a stock Limon the hyper
sub is a speedboat that turns into a
submarine this is really cool if it
sounds like a kid's James Bond fantasy
well that's exactly how it started out
for inventor Reynolds Mary oh I just
always figured it'd be a good idea as a
kid to be able to have a really cool
speedboat they could go out and dive
when you wanted to dive from youthful
minds these creations are now in the
hands of young warriors like corporal
Edmund Kennedy you've been in the
Marines for years and yet you got all
this top brass asking you what do you
think yes sir that's definitely a change
of pace he's one of the Marines
participating in the exercise and for
him a lot of the technology feels
familiar it was almost like being at
home and you might have it okay did you
ever think that
would be able to bring those video
gaming skills to the job 90 million
years my mother told me was a waste of
time but look at me now moe
now the Marines are going to take what
they learn here they're gonna narrow it
down and decide what they may want to
purchase for future deployment and they
promise that will happen fast thinks
Silicon Valley speed and not Pentagon
red tape Alex Carter thinks it's a brave
new world huh what's interesting to
beginning the internet began in
government now what's happening in
Silicon Valley is being adopted by
government right some of the smartest
machinery out there in advances and the
focus on cybersecurity new fronts on all
accounts